D-D-D-D-D-AD-D E-B-E-K-E-S-S-S-S-T-I-N-不 Metro地利
Theta-de-Ca-a-u-t-E...
I
Whee!
Wheeinno!
Wait, no.
What?
Hello?
We're live.
We're drawing.
Hello, everyone.
Oh.
Dampo, would you like to introduce yourself?
Hello.
I'm Dampo Fish.
I'm a friendly alien.
You might know me as the...
No, you don't.
Hello.
It is me.
I'm Dampo Fish.
I'm a friendly alien.
You might know me as the...
No, you don't.
Hello.
It is me.
Okay.
Good introduction.
Thank you for joining me today.
So...
Thank you.
Yeah, you're the original Childo Maker.
No, that's not me.
You, you, you, you, you did it.
You did it.
No, I haven't...
It came to you.
What?
You invented it.
I didn't invent the Childo you did.
No, I didn't...
Do you not want to take credit for it?
Why would...
I don't want to...
They're calling me the Childo Legend Ice Lady.
Yeah.
Are you not?
I'm the Dampo Fish, the Lady of Ice.
Yeah, are you not?
Lady of Ice.
I don't like the cold weather.
I hate it.
Well then, why did you make a Childo?
Because it was fun.
I mean, yeah, it is fun.
It is fun.
It is.
Oh.
Shit.
Okay.
Oh, right.
We should explain what we're drawing.
So this is our little reference for our thumbnail.
Excuse me.
This is our reference for our thumbnail for the ASMR video we're going to make together.
And I'm drawing Dampo and she's drawing me.
Yup.
It already started.
And I find it really hard.
I was saying to Amy before, but I find it really hard to draw a character for the first
time.
I feel like it always looks weird the first time you draw someone because you're so focused
on the design.
You're so focused on the design.
And the features.
Getting the features right.
Uh-huh.
I understand.
Oh.
Fuck.
What do you just do?
I'm fucking on my drawing like really badly right now.
Hold on.
I'm fucking up the layers.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Everything is on one layer.
Do you normally draw with a lot of layers over there?
Yeah, I do.
But I think I fucked it up an accidentally.
Uh.
Merged them?
Yeah.
I think it looks like it's on one layer.
I merged my layers by accident.
Are you shitting me?
Can't go back?
Oh, no.
It's so over.
God damn it.
Okay.
Man, it was going so well too.
This drawing program is a little...
No, it looks so good.
Yeah.
It's a bit weird.
It's a little laggy.
Yeah.
So I'm struggling a little bit on how to use it.
God damn it.
Damn it.
That's so frustrating.
I hate when that happens.
I have to redraw over it.
No.
Isn't there an undo button?
I can't undo any more than it currently is undone.
Yeah.
I limits the undoes.
I wonder if it's because it's like browser based.
Maybe you can't handle like infinite with so many people, but I don't know.
It probably just can't handle that many undoes.
Yeah.
It's too much.
They can't program it in.
Yeah.
Bitches.
Witches.
Denpa's Amy is looking cute.
It is.
You drew me so cute.
Thank you.
I feel like I want to like...
This is like my first go.
And as I was saying, I feel like it's kind of awkward because I'm...
I haven't drawn you before.
I wanted to draw you yesterday.
And I started like drawing strong.
And I was like, let me draw all the cute girls.
But it was so fucking hot since we...
I couldn't do it.
I was like lining her.
And I was like, I can't.
I can't.
I can't anymore.
It's okay.
You can always redraw.
Don't worry.
True.
And nothing is permanent.
It's as part of what makes art so cool.
You fuck up.
You can just try again.
Yeah.
Nothing's permanent.
Nothing is permanent.
Let's fucking go.
I do really like your poofy hair.
And that's pretty fun to draw.
I really like the...
The balls.
There's so many balls in your hair.
There is.
I got lots of balls.
Yeah.
It's very...
It's very fun.
I love to draw big poofy hair.
So like the...
The poofy pigtails and the poofy balls are really fun.
I'm glad you like them.
No.
I got huge balls.
Is that right?
Cat or something?
I would like to play with your hairballs.
Like bat them around.
That's cute.
Denpa's a balltuber?
I do like a lot of games with balls.
It's so bad.
I was trying to mention to you that I really like your pinpals.
Autocracked pinpals to pinballs.
Pinballs?
Five different times.
So I kind of like your pinpals.
I like your pinballs.
Yeah.
I couldn't stop calling them pinballs.
When are you restarting your...
Your donut gun?
I just...
It's mostly on Twitch, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm doing it on YouTube too.
I've been multi-streaming it.
But I don't really use YouTube that much.
Okay.
I was thinking about streaming this one just on YouTube.
But it was like...
I don't know how to use YouTube.
No, it's fair.
I don't fucking know how to use YouTube either.
I just wanted to link your...
I just wanted to link your stream so that people can...
Go check out...
Ah, gross, my voice.
Yeah, let me sit and chat.
Ah, fuck.
I don't have a waiting room setup for it or anything.
It's okay.
I'll link your Twitch.
Hold on.
And then...
How do I pinmessage?
Okay, there we go.
Go support Dinta.
Oh, you did the same thing as me.
I thought I made a new...
I literally thought I made a new one.
Fuck this drawing program.
I'm going to sue them.
I swear I did.
Maybe, like, I clicked it and then didn't register.
And thinking that might be what it was.
I'm going to sue them for emotional damages.
Hmm.
That's not even a thing of, like, naming our layers.
It's really, like, I thought I made a new layer and I didn't.
I think it was the same thing.
No, I accidentally merged my layers somehow.
I don't know how though.
It merged.
Yeah, I swear I made a new layer.
I swear I clicked on the new layer button and then just didn't make it.
Just didn't create it.
Oh, how rude.
Okay, you have, like, you got ears.
Wait, where the fuck?
Oh, no, wait.
I remember I had to delete the ears and then run.
I was about to freak out because I lost your ears for a second.
No!
Yeah, I don't have human ears.
I only have...
These are my ears only.
Okay.
They're like my antennas.
Intenas?
Intenas.
I didn't realize you didn't have human ears.
I'll delete the human ears.
There.
It's a secret.
It's a little known fact.
I don't have ears.
I don't like to hear anything.
I use...
I only communicate by receiving...
radio waves into my brain.
It goes directly into my brain.
Oh, do you communicate with other aliens like that?
Yeah.
Telepathically.
Here, I can send you messages telepathically right now.
Figure brain.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Are you receiving now?
I don't know.
What are you saying?
You told me.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're saying.
I think I don't really have Intenas to receive your messages.
Oh, no.
Still, the communication's yet again.
I'm sorry.
Oh, God.
My drawing looks...
I flipped it and it looks so fucked up.
I flipped it.
Oh, it looks so disgusting when I flip it.
Well, that's why you have to flip it often.
I always forget that I need to flip.
And then I flip it and constantly flip.
I go through phases with drawing where I flip the canvas too much.
And then I need to stop flipping it too much.
And then I just stop flipping it completely.
And then it cycles back.
And then I'm back to flipping constantly.
And then back to never flipping.
Just flip it constantly.
That's what I do.
True.
It's okay.
You don't have to be self-conscious about how much you flip a canvas.
No one's...
No one's worried about how often you flip a canvas.
You're safe.
You're safe here.
We don't judge you.
It's always the head, huh?
It's always the fucking head.
It's like you flip the head and it's like...
It doesn't even look like it's the same species anymore.
True.
That's why I just constantly flip it
so that way I can constantly fix the mistakes
that are forming as I'm drawing.
I'm trying to use your model as a reference.
I keep looking that over to you.
To your cute little face.
I've been looking at you too.
You have like big bangs.
So I was trying to think...
I wasn't sure how to draw your hair.
Because you're so like...
There's so much in your bangs.
It's like...
I'm not sure.
I'm trying to like work it out.
I'm doing my best.
Everyone in viewer has like humongous bangs.
I don't know if you've noticed.
We all have huge bangs.
Because I'm trying to figure out like...
Where do I begin?
There's so much of it.
You just...
So much of it.
But it's true.
Just try Strani too.
Yeah.
Strani's got huge bangs.
She's got a five head.
Yeah.
I was drawing Strani.
I'm like, oh my god.
It's kind of good her hair.
And there's so much bang.
There's so much on her head.
I'm having the same thing with you now.
You have like five different bangs.
You have like so many different clumps of bangs.
I don't know where to begin.
I know.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
The bangs...
What if the bangs are the friends we made along the way?
I must have a lot of friends though.
So many.
It's more of a helmet.
Do not think about what the skull looks like underneath.
I've seen what the skull looks like underneath.
And it's fucked.
No.
Don't see that about your skull.
Can you show me?
Maybe I can.
Let me see.
I gotta...
I won't judge you for saying it's huge.
Because maybe I'll agree once I see it.
But for now I'm judging you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
Let me remove my bangs then.
One second.
I gotta bring my face up close a little bit so I can see what I'm doing.
My...
It's rough.
I'm just gonna say it's rough, okay?
Prepare yourself.
Okay.
Wait, is it like dented?
Because of the rigging?
Because I know sometimes I have to do that where like...
I had to end up dented them so that you don't have like a bald preview.
It's not dented.
It's just a rough shape.
It's a really rough shape.
Yeah.
Bring it.
It's like really...
It's quite small.
My head is...
Oh, fuck, wrong button.
My head is quite small.
Are you seeing it form?
Wait, I'm not seeing it form.
I'm not seeing your head.
You're not seeing it?
Where's your baldness?
I don't see your baldness.
I'm going bald!
Where's your bald?
I'm working on it.
Do you not see it on your screen?
I don't see it.
Try looking at the stream.
I don't see it on the stream either.
Where's your...
Oh wait, I'm behind.
I'm behind.
Oh my god.
Ew, you look disgusting.
I didn't realize I was like behind.
I forgot that YouTube does that where it like puts you behind.
Oh, ew.
You look really gross.
You look foul.
I don't like the shadows look disgusting.
You look like there's something wrong with you.
I don't want you to be my little sister anymore.
You're like one of those helmet babies.
Helmet babies? What's that?
Have you seen the babies with the helmet?
No.
Because they have like a dented head.
Because from like being left to me down for two months.
So they need to like shape their hands back to normal.
Oh, so you put the helmets on them.
And that's what you look like.
I do have some dents sometimes.
You're right.
When I turn right, you can see my head.
Well, let me see your bald head.
Are you any better?
Huh?
Wait, I actually don't...
I've never seen myself bald before.
Okay, wait.
Become bald with me.
Wait, I don't want to do this on this one.
Because then it's too much work.
They do have the other...
Wait, let me...
Let me respawn.
Respawn.
Because I have the others that is just the head.
I don't want to have to unhide.
Hide and unhide.
Hide and unhide everything.
It's too much work.
I have one that's just my head.
Okay, show me your head.
Wait, okay.
Do you see this?
Does everyone see this?
No.
Don't see this.
I will wait for them to see this.
For you to see this, okay?
I look really scary.
I look really scary just to warn you.
This version is not for the faint of heart.
I'm ready.
I'm just a hand.
I'm going to become a bald hand.
I'm going to become a bald hand, okay?
Okay.
So you can...
We can be bald together.
Where's the...
Wait, why do I forget how to do this?
I literally know how to do this.
I found the bald button.
Okay.
Do it.
Do you see me?
I see you.
Oh, I'm still not reloaded.
It's going to take me so long to reload.
Oh, no.
I'm going to get so fucking jumpscared.
I see you.
Oh, no!
No!
Yeah, I'm just...
Whoa!
Yeah, I'm just the head with tentacles.
Yeah, show me your baldness.
Okay, I'll start.
There.
And then here.
I'm working on it.
I'll keep making myself bald, too.
There.
We will go bald together.
Shaving stream.
Head shaving stream.
You have ears.
I literally...
Like, I don't have ears.
Now you see.
I don't have ears.
Wait.
All of your hair is still there for me.
Oh, no.
Oh, fuck.
Does it not show up?
Wait.
Oh, no.
You can send me a screenshot.
Okay.
Oh.
I wonder why that is.
I guess this stuff doesn't show up on the...
Just share it.
Yeah, I'll share my YouTube studio with you.
And then maybe you can share it with the pinballs.
The pinballs might like it.
Yes.
Absolutely.
I'm almost becoming bald.
Me, too.
We're getting there.
Or maybe it'll update so everyone can see my baldness.
I look fucking terrifying.
Absolutely disgusting.
Don't worry.
I look just as bad.
I look like I need to be killed.
Are you allowed to say that on YouTube?
I don't know.
You can say it anyways though.
I don't care.
Oh, shit.
You're so fucking cool.
Okay.
I'm bald.
Ew.
It looks so disgusting.
I don't see it.
You're sharing it with me.
On Discord.
Okay.
I'm sharing with you.
Look at me.
Ew.
Do you see this?
Oh, it's not that bad.
It's not that bad.
Here, hold on.
Let me...
I look like a foul beast.
No, you look cute.
You're literally bullying me.
I'm not bullying you.
I'm saying you look cute.
Look at her.
She's so cute with her bald head.
You're weak with your people together.
What about when you see it with the tentacles?
How does it feel?
Is this like T.O.S.?
Why would it be T.O.S.?
I don't know.
Maybe it's like T.O.S.
No.
It's just like body horror T.O.S.
It's not horror.
It looks cute.
We're two bald babes.
Bald...
Yeah.
Bald together.
But also not bald together for some reason.
We come bald together.
We're both together in spirit.
Yeah.
I don't know why because they literally took off all this stuff.
It looks like my tentacles tickle your bald head.
I want them to tickle your bald head.
Wait.
Oh my God.
It's disgusting.
Yo.
Wait.
If I put them behind your bald head.
Let me position them.
Wait.
Ew.
Now this looks like you.
Wait.
Now I just have tentacles.
No.
It looks so cute.
Wait.
Ignore my legs.
Ignore my bald head.
There.
You belong to T.O.S.
You should have given your tentacles to Strani.
I feel like she's the one that needs tentacles more.
She has some on the video in the background.
But you can't really see them because they're really dark.
I take up a lot of space.
I look really imposing like this.
Actually they look quite threatening and cool.
The more I see myself bald the more I kind of like it.
Yeah.
You should stay bald forever.
Just like a bald floating head.
Yeah.
Become bald forever.
Still just a head.
I forgot that they just still see just a head.
Okay.
Let me.
I don't remember which one.
I think this is the right one.
I'm just putting it.
I'm the final real V3.
I don't know this was it.
I'm putting all my hair back now.
No.
This isn't it.
That one is not it.
Ignore that.
Chad you didn't see that.
Chad.
Don't.
That one's not it.
So I don't really feel this.
Yeah.
That's me.
I'm loading I'm spawning.
No.
It's the bald one again.
I didn't mean to be bald.
I don't want the bald nothing fish.
Take your time.
Take it.
I can.
You should follow me.
Take it under your eyes.
I can appreciate a bulb then for fish there's no pressure to become to grow
hair there you are
I'm back. I'm normal now. I'm normal again. I'm normal. I was always normal. Yeah you
Nothing happened
Oops I grew. I didn't mean to be bald again.
Oh my god my eyes are so big and bulky.
I make big eyes. You like big anime girl eyes?
Yeah, I like to make them like fucking huge. It just feels right and you just have a face
that was meant for big fucking you guys. I do have really big big eyes don't I?
Yeah, maybe these are like too big. Maybe I want too big with it. I don't know.
And there's no such thing as too big. I like big eyes. Very mowing.
Big beautiful eyes.
Playing with my bald head ASMR is POV slapping your bald head ASMR.
That's like such a good idea for an ASMR video. What do you mean?
Bald people are really scary though.
You're afraid of bald people?
Yeah well the ones with the shiny hands. I'm scared of them when their hands are shiny.
Why?
Because it's like why is there they like must oil them up right?
You think bald people with shiny heads oil up their heads?
Yeah which makes it scary because I like think about this guy like wakes up and he oils like his bald head.
Yeah what a fucking loser. He wakes up and oils his bald head.
I don't think it's a loser. I just think it seems like a scary sort of person.
I don't want to think about the kind of person that wakes up and rubs the oil on their bald head.
I need my bald head to be shiny today.
You think they got some weird morals? They're focusing on the wrong things in life?
Yeah just like why are you waking up and oiling your heads?
Yeah but why are you polishing it?
I don't want them to polish it.
It makes you uncomfortable to look at it? Do you see your reflection in their bald shiny head?
Sometimes but also I think I just like I don't know the idea of like oiling up my head personally makes me uncomfortable.
Like hair oil like makes sense but I think about like putting oil on my bald head and this seems really unpleasant.
Well maybe they just have a really they might have a really dry scalp you know?
How does it feel? How do you think it feels?
Having a dry scalp?
No like wheeling. Imagine like the feeling of your hands like wheeling up your bald head.
You could do ASMR oiling my bald head.
ASMR oiling up my bald head in the morning to prepare for my day.
Yeah.
Of making everyone uncomfortable with my oily bald head.
Yeah it's disgusting.
You could be some gross and bald.
The reason bald heads are shiny is because the head naturally produces oil. People aren't oiling their heads.
Yeah that makes sense.
Yeah that does make more sense because like just like the image of somebody like oiling up their bald head.
That is a really scary sort of person.
I don't I agree. I agree with the chatter though. I don't think they're actually oiling themselves up.
I think it's just their um...
Yeah it's really true.
It's just their their head naturally producing the oil you know?
They don't do it on purpose.
Do you get like oily?
Oh I guess super oily. My hair is really oily. Do you not?
Yeah not really you know my hair is like I guess it's too like thick and curly.
It just gets very dry and my scalp is like it'll get itchy but it doesn't get oily.
It doesn't get greasy.
Oh what the hell you're so lucky. Mine gets super greasy and gross.
It is lucky.
My hair isn't shiny though because I don't get oily.
And if I had like a bald head I would just have the dry bald head that I would need the oil because I don't get oily myself.
But shiny doesn't look good. It looks greasy. It doesn't look shiny.
That's true.
Like it doesn't...
Oh it looks kinda cute. Oh you're drawing me in a honeymoon. Maybe I'll draw you in like a comfy fit.
Oh that'll be cute. No I like it. I'm dutching.
I'll give you your pens though.
I'm just drawing it in something simple but it's kind of awkwardly.
It's rough.
You like hoodies? That's good.
Coffee cardigan? I don't know.
Using all natural emi hair oil to cook your food.
You could deep fry in the amount of oil I produce in a week.
Meow meow meow.
You could deep fry some french fries in there.
Does that not sound tasty?
I don't like it.
No? You don't want to deep fry your french fries in my hair oil?
No.
Oh that's a shame.
Imagine McDonald's french fries with deep fried and emi oil.
What would you call them?
Emi fries.
Frimmies. I don't know.
Frimmies?
Frimmies.
Frimmies. I like Frimmies.
Frimmie fries.
Frimmies.
I know there's a place I forget where but if you order like fries and onion rings they call them like rings.
That almost sounds like like frimmie.
Fring.
Frings?
Frings. Fries and onion rings together.
Oh I never heard of that.
Emifries with a side of emi need to wash it down? You are disgusting.
Disgusting. Disgusting. Ew.
Do you like milk?
Um not really. Like I like milk with um coffee but I don't like milk like alone really.
I like milk with other stuff basically but not alone.
Oh my god you drank me a little cardigan too. It's so cute.
No I thought that would fit. It was really comfy.
It was a bit the same. So comfy.
Mm-hmm.
My chat keeps getting me into trying to collaborate with um Canadian dairy farmers.
They're saying I need to I need to collaborate with Canadian dairy farmers.
Oh my god your chat's trying to milk you and they're trying to get you to sell your milk right? Is that what it's going on?
No. No they literally just want me to collaborate with like Canadian farmers for some reason.
It's like as a sponsor. They want me to be sponsored by big milk.
Wait so they don't want you to sell your milk? I thought they were trying to get you to sell your milk like in collaboration with dairy farmers.
Like they're trying to get you to get milked.
No they want me to be like be sponsored by the milk.
Huh are you a fan of milk? Are you a big milk milk fan?
Not at all. I'm very lactose intolerant.
You're lactose intolerant?
Yeah unfortunately. I still like cheese a lot but it doesn't it doesn't love you know?
Mm-hmm that sucks. Yeah why is your chat trying to get you to collab with Canadian dairy farmers if you're lactose intolerant?
I guess you could you could you could make your own like special flavor of lactose free milk with them.
Then put flavor to lactose free.
I don't want to be the first VTuber with the Canadian dairy farms sponsorship.
I can do it with you. We can both do it.
The Canadian dairy farm VTubers.
Yeah the first VTubers.
The first VTubers that collabed with Canadian dairy farms.
Yeah VTuber dairy farmer collab. Let's fucking go. There's a totally huge market for this.
I bet there is. I'm sure lots of people would want to buy our milk.
Yeah it's an untapped market.
I'm struggling so hard with your sweater here I'm gonna move on to something else.
You know when these are hard to draw.
I don't know how to draw.
If it means wait oh go ahead.
Amigo?
Yeah you go.
I was just gonna read a chat message that says when Amy gets a gamer subs flavor is it emi milk or emi nade?
Neither! Neither! Neither!
The idea of like a milk energy drink seems a bit disgusting.
I don't know if it exists. I'm sure it probably is like one of the name flavors or flavor names but I don't know.
Milk. Gamer milk. Gamer milk, Gamer subs.
Gamer milk sounds disgusting. Gamer milk is the name.
How do I move my whole drawing here? There we go. Give you some more space.
Let me give you thigh highs because it's cute.
It is cute. I like thigh highs.
Gamer emi nade or we riot? Riot then.
Oh wait I just realized it's the gamer thing because it's like oh the lemonade.
Oh wait I think I get it not a whole though. I was wondering why lemonade. I thought maybe you just like lemonade.
No it's piss.
You didn't know it was piss?
No I'm just I well I realized but only like just just now.
You poor innocent soul. No emi nade is piss. It's not lemonade.
That's why it's called like emi nade because it's yellow.
It looks like lemonade but it's not. It's pee.
You've been you've been corrupted now.
Why would you do this to me?
I didn't do anything.
I thought you were innocent. I thought you were innocent vtuber.
You thought we were innocent vtubers?
Yes.
Oh shit I'm glad I was able to trick you at least.
Say so.
No I never claimed to be anything.
That's your own fault for coming up with those conclusions.
Well you just look innocent.
I do I've been told that.
Say so company. Does she know?
No.
Do I know what?
What do you mean do you know? Do you know?
What do I know? What do I not know? What don't I know?
Does she know? Do you know what we do?
What do you do?
Do you introduce yourself to the chat?
I don't have to introduce myself to the chat right now?
Yeah you can introduce yourself.
Oh my god okay hi.
I'm Amy V.
From Bieler's Generation 1 in Dolce.
And Bieler is the first
English AVtuber company
which means we are the first English company to focus on making porn.
There we go.
What is porn?
What is porn? Oh my god.
Chat you're gonna have to you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to grab the the wheel right now.
You're gonna have to take over chat.
Can we explain to Tenville what's porn?
What's short for popcorn?
Wait that's so awesome you guys are a popcorn company.
It's corn but with a P.
Popcorn.
What's your favorite kind of...
Oh that's why you kind of look like a popcorn kernel.
I wear your hands kind of like a popcorn.
You're right.
No don't don't you're popcorn detubers.
You're like a popcorn kernel.
Your hair is like a freshly popped kernel.
And then the little brown things are the kernels themselves.
The kernels before becoming popcorns.
Exactly.
Yeah.
We're popcorn v-tubers.
Popcorn.
Do you have a favorite type of popcorn Denpa?
I like...
I'm actually not really a big popcorn fan to be honest.
I'm not particularly fond.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm not big on it.
I guess...
I like classic like butter.
Maybe in like dill pickle or like salt and vinegar flavor powdering.
But then I don't know.
I'm not really a big popcorn person.
I like savory stuff though.
I'm a pretty big popcorn person.
Do you know kernels?
Kernels?
Yeah like the brand that does like the weird popcorn.
I've heard of it.
I'm a big kernels fan.
You haven't had kernels?
I haven't had them like I've seen them.
But I haven't tried it because it's popcorn.
Like I'm already not like a big popcorn fan.
You should try kernels.
We should go get kernels together one day.
It's freaking delicious.
I love kernels.
They have a bunch of really good flavors of popcorn.
Isn't like sweet though?
I don't really like like a sweet popcorn.
I like caramel corn.
I hate that too.
I hate it.
I love snacks but I fucking hate that.
That is one thing I like refuse to eat.
It's fucking foul.
It's so disgusting and it's so popular too.
That's why it's everywhere.
It's like everyone loves that type of popcorn for some reason.
I hate it.
Like both the texture and like the flavor itself.
But I think it's mostly like the textures.
It's awful.
Not really like a big fan of caramel.
I guess in general.
But like the texture of caramel corn.
It's horrible.
It's awful.
I don't know what you mean.
I know what you mean.
What kind of flavors does kernels have?
I mean like savory and like sweet.
Yeah there's a lot of savory flavors.
They have like um
different types of cheese flavors.
They do have dill pickle.
I tried their pickle it was pretty good.
And I usually don't like pickle flavored things.
They have like um
they have spicy flavored popcorn
which is really good too.
That sounds really good.
I would probably like something with that.
Do you like spicy things?
Is that why you've been eating the spicy
um beans?
The spicy jelly beans?
Oh yeah I got them.
Sometimes because it just like
gives me a bit of a quick thrill.
But yeah no I spilled them all over the floor
before I was streaming.
And I had to like
be right back because I had to pick up the beans off my floor.
It's like Fiery 5 jelly belly ones.
And me was making fun of me.
She called me disgusting pig.
I did not say that!
What?
She did.
I didn't call you anything.
You told me to come over
and eat the jelly beans off of your floor.
Do you want to?
No.
I don't like spicy jelly beans.
You eat spicy popcorn.
Yeah but that's different.
It's like flavorful.
But jelly beans are sweet right?
Yeah but these are spicy.
There's no sweetness.
There's no sweetness at all?
No it's just hot.
It's just hot jelly beans.
That sounds gross.
They are.
They are. You should try them.
It's disgusting you should try it.
You don't want to suffer alone
eating those nasty jelly beans?
No I want you to suffer with me.
Better to suffer with somebody else.
I guess it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm really struggling to make this arm look good
but I think I'm going to color it too now.
Yeah.
I guess cleaning.
I do have so many sketches and I sketch
and then I sketch and then I sketch.
It's just slowly like adding more.
I think now I'm like
this is like my clean clean sketch.
This is like your third sketch now?
Yeah.
Because I started like super
super loosely.
Kind of build up I guess.
I wasn't sure.
I guess it comes back to like as I was saying
the first time you draw a character
it just feels so awkward because
you're focused mostly on getting the design right
and then I switch to the sweater and I'm like
you know what this is better.
Let's focus on like the little details.
How do I
make it so that I can only draw
on the layered self?
Like only draw on whatever I've already
drawn on.
I don't know how to explain myself.
No I think I know.
It's the lock button.
The lock button.
But it doesn't work.
Oh no.
Wait.
Maybe I'm using the wrong layer.
Wait what?
I actually forget how to do
you mean alpha lock right?
I think that is the button that does it on this program.
Yeah.
You don't remember.
Alpha lock.
What?
I forget how
I literally forget how we
what the fuck how do I do it?
Opacity lock? Masking layer?
Yeah something like that like a masking layer.
Because I used to be able to do that.
Where is it now?
Oh wait I think
Is that it?
Oh it's the little
It's the what?
It's the new screenshot. I found the button.
Okay.
It's
This is like so fucking weird and
hidden but it's the one next to the layer
opacity and you click the lock.
The little square.
Oh I see it. Okay thank you.
Thank you.
I'm just learning. I'm just learning
that that is where it is for myself too.
That's better.
It's a really weird place to have it.
It is.
I handsily
look around because it's a queen.
Oh shit.
Now is there an airbrush button too?
You need to
you need to change the brush.
So there's like other brush settings
so it'll be like a softer brush.
If you scroll down there's like
Oh my brushes.
Oh no that's not it.
There's plus and then there's like general
and then there's like soft, softer
softer. Okay.
Thank you.
I can't believe that you birth on stream.
I was really shocked when I heard you birth.
What?
What do you mean you can't believe I birth?
I just can't believe you do it.
Do you not do it?
I don't birth on stream.
I never live.
Why not?
I don't know. I just don't like it. It scares me.
Are you afraid of people like
judging you for burping on stream?
No I think like
caring in. I was fine with you doing it
because like you're cute but usually I just
feel scared when like people burp.
You're afraid of people burping?
Yeah.
It's just like really scary.
Are you one of those people that think burping
is like gross?
I guess so but also I think it's
almost like I'm afraid they're gonna like throw up.
Oh.
Do you have a fear of like throwing up?
I think so. Just a bit.
I think just a bit.
Like are you are you afraid that
when you hear the sound of someone throwing up
you're gonna throw up too?
Yeah and I'm like oh my god they're gonna like throw up.
It's gonna throw up.
Oh.
So when they're burping it sounds like
oh my god like they're gonna puke.
Mmm.
Okay.
You would not like
you would not like some of the stuff
I've posted on Twitter then.
I've heard some of it.
They click off and it gets scary.
It gets scary.
That's okay.
It's pretty scary. It can get pretty scary.
Yeah.
It's really terrifying.
I don't want you to throw up.
I started worrying. I feel bad.
Oh my goodness she's sick and she's going to die.
Don't feel bad.
I'm fine.
Don't worry.
Everyone's always worrying about you though.
Especially when it comes to ice.
They think you're gonna like kill yourself.
Yeah they think I'm gonna
Are you allowed to say that word on YouTube?
I keep worrying. I said something like Q.S.
Say what? Ice?
The K word.
Oh.
Kill myself?
Just K.
K I L L.
Are you allowed to say that?
Oh I don't know but I say it anyways.
Like literally half of my VODs
are limited ads but I don't care
I just don't really make money anyways.
So say whatever you want. It's okay.
Oh okay I thought it would get like your
You're like suspended.
No.
I mean if that happens it happens whatever.
It's okay.
I didn't know.
I just think yeah I have a bit of the tiktok
because I know you're not allowed to say stuff like that on there.
I don't stream on tiktok
but I was thinking
like maybe YouTube is like that.
YouTube is pretty strict. It's annoying.
It's like
you can say so much on Twitch
and on YouTube if you say the same stuff
your like video is gonna get
limited ads or
or even like
taken down.
Yeah. Yeah I'm very paranoid.
I didn't really use YouTube much
until recently I've been posting
more. I'm like
I'm so confused about like what gets
limited.
Didn't you have a video where you
like it was like
sucking on a popsicle until it's gone?
What happened to it? I saw it wasn't up anymore.
I got
scared so I got rid of it
because I was afraid YouTube would kill me for it.
I don't know if they will.
You can't rid of it for now anyways
because I'm like what if they kill my channel
for it. Like it's been up but
maybe they'll change their mind.
Oh.
You took it down because you were afraid
they were gonna like remove your channel for it?
Yeah.
I don't want them to kill me.
No.
If they didn't take it down when you first
uploaded it it was probably fine.
Really?
Yeah I'll leave it. I mean I don't
don't blame me if something happens to your channel
but I would have left it up.
You're gonna be like
mass reporting me.
I would not mass report you.
No.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll put it back.
I don't know. I just got scared.
It got so popular though. People loved it.
But what if my YouTube gets killed?
No.
They give you a warning first.
Oh.
I thought like it's just over.
No no no. They give you a warning
and then
if you fuck up again they give you a strike
and then if you fuck up again they give you another strike
and then if you fuck up again they give you a third strike
and you might be out after the third strike
I don't know.
I just feel as if I made your eyes way too fucking big.
I'm like what the fuck?
I'm like blind.
I turned you into a bug.
What the fuck? I'm cooked.
My brain is cooked.
I just need to make the irises smaller.
I don't know what the fuck I was cooking.
It's okay.
I like actually
looked at him like oh fuck.
What am I doing?
I got those big bug eyes.
Those beautiful big unsettling bug eyes.
I want them to be big but not that big.
Not that big.
Okay this is better I think.
I think this is like less.
Yeah.
Okay. I think this looks better.
You saw it before right? This is like less.
Bucketing.
Oh my cat.
What is he doing?
What? Like what's the mean?
He doesn't like you the mean.
You like him me.
Hello?
What was your cat's name again? I forgot.
It was something cute like lemon?
Yeah. That's him.
His name was Lemon?
Yeah.
Oh my god hi Lemon.
He left already. He doesn't.
He's scared of you.
I am pretty scary.
I understand.
You have to teach me how to use this score.
Because I couldn't guess all the other work.
Oh.
I'm confused again.
Did I accidentally draw on the wrong layer?
What am I doing wrong here?
It.
I can't do it.
The hair looks like it's all the same layer.
Like the hair coloring.
No I drew some of the hair on the wrong layer.
I'm copying it right now.
This is layer 2 copy.
I don't know.
What the fuck?
What is happening?
Huh?
I hate this program.
What the fuck?
No.
This video is not sponsored.
We need you to fix your
fucking website.
You're listening.
They're definitely not listening.
Wait maybe they are. Maybe they're listening.
I wish they were.
If Magma people are listening.
Help.
Well no let me help you.
I have a lot of ideas for you.
Yeah.
And the first one is to fix all the bugs.
There we go. Fix all of them.
And also what the fuck is
the opacity lock button? That is so weird.
Why is it like
a weird hidden toggle next to the
layer opacity?
I've never seen it like that before.
I don't think any other program has it
in that area.
Very strange.
I think I'm getting it.
Watch me have to redraw the whole thing
because I didn't get it.
Okay I think I fixed it.
There. Now it's all in the right layer.
Yeah.
Amy draws the thumbnail
to her ASMR. Yes I will.
I will be drawing.
Ten put do you want me to include that you're drawing
in the thumbnail for our collab too?
Yeah.
If you like it. If it's ugly then don't add it.
No we can
include both drawings. It's okay.
Yeah I don't want it if it's ugly.
It shouldn't be in it.
It's just that I would want it to be finished.
Do you think you could finish it or no?
I think I could.
I'm not sure what considers like a finished drawing though.
I usually like sketch.
I think like
I don't know. I guess
like this plus colors
and some rendering.
That is dumb.
We'll see. What do you consider
finished?
I consider finished to be like
clean lines
and clean shading.
You know what I mean?
The way I'm coloring
I'm just coloring my own sketch right now.
This isn't finished
for me.
Yeah
all of a sudden you're like
I could
finish.
This is starting to like fuck when I'm
I'm really thinking this is
kind of philosophical.
What is a finished drawing?
Yeah.
What does it mean?
What does it mean to finish a drawing?
Yeah.
Okay. I mean like
I guess this is like a sketch
but like this is like
like a rendered sketch.
Nor the fucked up eyes.
I was suffering from
heat.
It's okay.
I'm suffering from heat too right now.
Okay.
Onesan
You can
You can be the big sister.
I feel like
after actually talking to you
I feel like you might be more mature than
me in this game.
You think I'm
You have this picture you had to use discord.
No.
I'm more mature than you.
Me? No.
No.
Big sister in me this is illegal.
I always wanted to have
a little sister.
I'll be your little sister.
Okay.
For real.
I need the tier
of the
tiered member subs.
We know they're in membership tiers.
Yeah. There's membership tiers on YouTube.
I will
subscribe tier.
I will member tier membership
tier on the highest tier.
Why?
Why would you do that?
Because
I was horny.
That's why
Huh?
He's so confused about me.
What is going on here?
What the fuck?
Did I like duplicate my layers?
I'm so fucking confused.
No. I'm confused. What?
That's what I'm saying. It's really confusing to draw
on this program.
This is why you're literally...
Is there anything on my layer 5?
Layer 3.
I hide. Layer 5.
I have everything hidden,
but it's still showing
something. What if I delete it?
I don't even know what I just deleted.
What if I delete this? Okay.
No, it's bugging. It's actually
fucking bugging.
This shit is actually fucking bugged.
It is bugged.
Well...
It's fucking over.
It's over.
This program sucks. Why is it bugging?
Literally, I deleted the layer.
I still don't know what's going on here.
As soon as it's bugging.
Here we go.
This sweater falling off her arm is so cute.
Yeah, the way she drew it falling off is super cute.
Thank you.
I thought it would be like a cute touch.
I really like armpits.
I wanted to give like a touch of armpit.
You like armpits?
Yeah.
I think it's just cute.
It's nice to see it.
It's nice when you can see a touch of armpit.
You like seeing a touch of the armpit?
What is that about armpits that you like?
I don't know.
It's just a touch of skin.
It's cute when
a girl is mostly covered
but you just see
a little bit of something
and you're like, wow.
It's very scandalous. It's just exciting.
When a woman who's
she's wearing a dress
that covers everything but then it like falls off.
You know, like imagine
she's in a beautiful bridal gown.
She's a beautiful bride
and then her like sleeve
slips so you see like a touch of her armpit.
I see.
Like an armpit fold.
Oh.
You understand all.
Okay, it's scandalous.
Like a nun.
A nun with a little bit of armpit falling out.
Yeah.
Then you're like, oh my god.
It's exciting.
It is exciting.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I'm not really sure how to explain it
but then they can also be sweaty
and they can also like that's just one
aspect of makes them fucking awesome
but there's also like, well
there's so many different flavors of armpits.
They can be sweaty. They can be like
kind of
what is it?
Sexual innuendo.
What's your favorite flavor of armpit?
Armpit Aussie.
Armpit Aussie?
Yeah.
What is armpit Aussie?
It's like when it looks
like there's like, okay.
So let me just like
add this to my drawing really quickly.
Why is it not
hiding this?
See, I just like
went in and I like
draw these little folds
and you just start to form like
little armpit Aussie.
Maybe you can do like a little like
soft
shading here
that like gives a little touch and then you add
like a little bit of shine and it's like
there's like some armpit Aussie
like that.
I think I know what you mean.
Yeah, I think I know what you mean.
It's like really zoom in
on that. It was zoom in on the
armpit Aussie that I just drew.
So you didn't get the vision.
Zoom in. I zoomed in.
Do you guys get the armpit Aussie
vision?
Yeah, it's just like the little
little detail.
It's a little armpit.
It's a little armpit Aussie.
Yeah, you don't get to see
her cleavage but you get to see
her armpit. Isn't that good enough for you?
It is. For me, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No cleavage but you get
a bit of the armpit. So it's like exciting.
Like I don't get the tits but I get the armpit.
Awesome.
I mean the armpit, who needs
tits when you got armpit, you know?
Exactly, literally exactly.
Why pussy when armpit?
Just...
Just use the pit.
Just use the tits. It's so powerful.
It's like set-tie
really?
What's that?
It's like the tie-high.
It's also happening in this image.
It's the gap between the
tie and the tie-high.
That's what it's called?
The tie-releaky.
It's usually when they have also like a
school girl uniform with the skirt
and then, yeah, absolute territory.
So you have the area between
the ties, like the naked ties,
the tie-high and the skirt.
And there's also like
the tie-pudge.
The tie-releaky.
Absolute territory.
Oh, absolute...
Absolutely territory?
What is... Why is it called that?
The absolute territory.
Absolute territory.
It's like...
I switched to no, I don't remember what I was using.
It's so over for me.
What color do you want your sweater to be?
I don't know.
I don't know. I like pink.
You like pink? Pink is good.
Pink is a good color, you're right.
I'll make it pink.
Giving me the absolute territory.
Give me the absolute territory?
And I will make it...
I don't know.
You made me slow today.
Where is my... What size is this?
Is this even the same brush?
Well, I'm using this one now I guess.
You made me look like a cute little...
a cute little femme-boy there.
No!
It's cute!
I don't want you to look like
a cute femme-boy.
It's probably because I don't have hair yet.
You just got to add the hair buns.
That's all.
I got distracted.
I'm working slowly.
I don't want you to be a femme-boy.
You have something against femme-boys?
No.
Clearly I love them.
Clearly?
Clearly, yeah.
That's why I drew you like a femme-boy because I love them.
Okay, okay.
Whatever is underneath
Amy's Band-Aid is my idea of
absolute territory.
Under my Band-Aid
like on my nose?
I removed my nose Band-Aid
once because I was...
I'm working on adding stuff to my model.
And I just look really naked
and I also just look like Voldemort.
I look like I have no nose if I remove the Band-Aid.
No!
I also add
a certain appeal because
it's like the armpit thing.
You don't normally see your nose.
What if I see it?
Suddenly even your nose is scandalous because
we never get to see it.
But we see your nose and it sucks.
You see my nose and it's sexy
because you never get to see it.
Yeah, so it feels
infinite when you finally get to see it.
It's like seeing
a girl without makeup for the first time.
Mmm...
It's intimate.
Yeah!
Oops, crap.
Um...
Oh...
Okay.
Suddenly even the nose is like
oh my god, I'm so blessed to see her nose.
I'll show you my nose one day.
Well, I feel like
that might be too intimate, too soon.
Too soon?
We'll work up to it slowly then.
Don't get... don't be nervous, it's okay.
I didn't know you were...
I didn't know you were that type of girl.
To show my nose so quickly?
Yeah...
Oh...
I'm sorry. I won't show you my nose then.
If you don't want to see my disgusting nose,
I won't show it to you.
I don't think you should
ever do a nose reveal.
No?
No, because it's too intimate.
What if we see your nose?
Well, that's the point of a nose reveal.
No, don't reveal it.
Don't reveal it? Keep it a secret?
Yeah.
What if we...
Only spots show their nose.
You're not a spot, are you?
No, no, no.
If you reveal it for marriage,
I'll save the nose reveal for marriage.
Yeah, after...
Once you get married on your honeymoon,
you can be like...
Yeah, we're married now.
You can peel off the bandage, baby.
You peel it off and you have the most ugly nose.
I was gonna say...
I peel it off and my nose just falls off
because the bandage is what was holding my nose off.
No!
It's disgusting!
Have you seen that woman
she used to use like the salve or something
on her nose like the black salve
and her nose literally like wrought at it off
like is that too gruesome? I think that might be too gruesome.
She used what?
She used like...
There's this stuff called like black salve
and people use it as like alternative cancer
therapy for like skin cancer
because they have to get like
kills of the cancer cells
so they like put it on and then like wroughts their skin
and she did it on like a mole on her nose
and then her nose fell off.
Oh my god.
That sounds like something I would do.
I've looked up like
those like mole removal creams
and I was like
oh I want to use those so badly.
You know?
Why?
Because I have a lot of moles and I don't like them all
so I want to get rid of them.
Wait, I thought you said nose for some reason.
I didn't realize that you said mole.
So I was like what the fuck?
A nose removal cream?
Yeah, I was like
what the fuck?
No, mole removal
not nose removal.
Oh, like
ugly moles are nice moles.
What's the difference?
Well, there's like
ugly moles that like bulge out
and they have like a little hair.
Do you have those?
No, I don't have bulging out moles.
Oh, that's awesome though.
Not really.
But I have seen
I used to have a piano teacher that had a lot of the bulging out moles
and they would bulge out
so much
that they would have so little like
skin connecting the mole
to the you know to her body
and sometimes I just wanted to grab her
like bulging out moles and rip them off
because it's like they look like
they're about to fall off by themselves anyways.
I really want to just rip them off.
Like that's what I would do if I was her.
No, I get it.
But I'm also
disgusting but also I get it because
like I feel the same way but that yeah
that's what I mean by like gross mole.
I guess those are like skin tags basically.
Yeah, like skin tags.
Yeah.
Why did you put the blood
the blood toggle on your model?
Because I thought it was appropriate.
It is appropriate.
No, if I had those like
I don't know how people who have those
have those because like
that would be just coming off
like that is not...
I'm ripping that off of myself.
Yeah, if it was me I would be ripping it off too
like I would be simping it off with some scissors.
I'm guessing it's probably
painful for them to do that.
Yeah, I guess it must be painful but
like I don't think I could resist
like even like appearance
aside I just
I can't resist picking it.
I would see it as like a joy to remove it.
Like a treat.
Yeah, it's like a love treat.
Yeah.
You should be careful
damaging moles they can turn to melanomas
if they get injured too much.
Wait, do they grow back?
I think they do grow back
if you like
try to do it yourself.
What the fuck? Are you serious?
Yeah.
I can never get rid of the moles.
You can go to a doctor
I think it's pretty cheap to get them like properly removed.
Yeah, but if they grow back again
what's the point?
No, like they actually remove
because I think they like remove the roots or something
they don't usually come back
if you get them like surgically removed
but if you do them yourself
like you don't go that deep I think.
Oh, I'll go deep myself.
I'll go deep myself.
I'll get it myself.
I can't even heal.
Don't hit me.
I can do it.
I got it.
Don't worry guys, I'll do it.
I'll do it before and after.
I'll do it mole removal stream.
Come on, I believe in you.
Thank you.
I believe in your abilities.
I'm gonna come back
when I get bloody in the mole removal stream.
I can't breathe.
Don't do this at home kids.
Don't do this.
I was thinking like
I'm surprised nobody's done like
I mean maybe somebody's done it
but like hair cutting streams aren't common.
True.
Like why doesn't anyone do like hair cutting streams?
If I was a flesh tuber I would
when I was a flesh tuber I wanted to do a stream
where I shaved my eyebrows off.
I thought that would be really fun.
That sounds like good content.
If you're somebody who's like
cutting your hair frequently anyway
you might as well make a stream of it.
Yeah, I cut my own hair yeah
and I used to shave my eyebrows off too
so it would be fun.
Did you like draw them back on?
Yeah, I did.
I would draw them in fun colors
like pink and purple.
It's a pretty type of thing.
I shaved my eyebrows once
and I regretted it because
it's really annoying. It's really hard to draw them back on.
But then I grew back.
It can be hard.
It can be hard to draw them back on yeah.
But I have really, I have like really small eyebrows
so it's like
not much work.
Mine are big.
I like big brows.
I wish I had bigger brows.
Mine are really small and hard to see sometimes.
It's really not that much of a difference
whether I
shave them off or not
because most of the time they're hard to see anyways.
I have a lot of hair
and everything so
I need to get the right color
of hair for me.
Like
strawberry blonde?
I'm supposed to be ginger.
I thought you were like
strawberry blonde.
Everyone does.
Everyone thinks I'm blonde.
I thought I was blonde too
but no, I'm supposed to be ginger.
Same thing?
Like this is close as a color
at least this is like the shading color.
This is like the darker color.
This is kind of the lighter
you think?
Yeah, like this.
Yeah, I look very blonde.
Getting the colors hard.
Can I make
groups like folders
with this?
Alright, that's okay.
I'm not big of a deal.
I'm just gonna merge them.
I'm not doing everything
unless you link one there.
So you admit you're ginger?
Well, if I'm supposed to be ginger
I'm fucking ginger.
Whatever.
I'm just annoyed that I don't look ginger, you know?
Like if I'm gonna be ginger.
I mean, I don't think it'd be
harder to make.
You could just like up the saturation.
Yeah, I really thought
strawberry blonde is really cute though.
I don't see many strawberry blonde
YouTubers.
I see ginger.
I don't see many strawberry blondes.
I don't see many ginger YouTubers.
I guess not, yeah.
I see blondes a lot though
for sure.
But not many ginger.
Which is fair, because
ginger has no soul.
So why would you want to be ginger?
What the heck?
You're not gonna eat ginger, bro.
I know.
I'm built.
Where did your soul go?
That the more, that the reason for the more?
You're ginger with no soul,
so you do.
I do witchcraft.
I'm a Satanist
because I'm a ginger with no soul.
Yeah, that is the lure.
Holy fucking shit.
Lore drop, lore drop.
Lore drop?
I'm trying to do
some line art now, but
it's gone.
It's gone.
I'm just gonna consider that my
line art and doing
what I can with it.
Do what you can.
We'll work better in our
own drawing programs.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it looks pretty cute.
Lore's looks pretty cute.
Yours looks adorable.
I'm just struggling through it.
It's okay.
I'll add more ginger in this.
I think for the flat, I'll just see the main.
Blonde.
I'll add the ginger with the shading.
The ginger comes later.
Okay.
It'll make sense now.
Then put cooking on that lure.
She's building on my lure for me.
Wait, I thought that was
literally your lure.
Did I just make it up?
Well, it is my lure, but
the ginger I didn't think
had anything
to do with it.
You just linked.
I just made up your lure by accident
that I thought was already your lure.
No, at least I don't think the ginger
has anything to do with it.
Maybe it did. Maybe they were like,
let's make her ginger if she's gonna
be a satanist. She's gotta be ginger
because they have no souls.
Yeah, exactly.
They were thinking about it.
Maybe, I don't know.
They're racist against genders.
Are you allowed to say that word on YouTube?
Racist?
Yeah. Of course you can say racist.
No one's here.
No one's here to stop you.
Am I going crazy internally
because her lines
aren't perfect enough for her? Yes.
This drawing program
sucks balls.
So, of course...
Drawing just casual...
Yeah, it's meant for fun drawings
with friends, so it's okay.
Don't use it seriously though.
It's also annoying.
They implemented
so many silly things that no one would ever want
but there's basic stuff that
you just can't do in it.
Wait, what did they implement?
They added AI to this,
which I don't even understand.
Why would you need AI for a group drawing program?
What are you gonna do?
They added AI?
Yeah.
I think it's for...
I don't know, I think just like generating concepts.
But then...
there isn't even like a blend tool.
I don't know.
There isn't a blend tool?
But they add AI?
They make the AI blend it for you?
I don't really understand.
And then there's like a weird chat
and there's voice calling in this.
True.
There's a chat and voice calling.
Who the fuck is using voice call
in the magma?
If you're drawing with a friend,
you're probably already in a voice call.
Yeah, like why would you...
and I assume the voice call in here,
maybe it is like really good.
But why? What is the purpose?
Just give me a blend tool.
John Vealer confirmed this lore
in the Vealer lore podcast.
Who the fuck is John Vealer?
What are you talking about?
Magma more like smegma?
No, not smegma.
Magma more like smegma.
Do you like smegma?
I like smells.
You like smegma?
No, smells.
Not smegma.
When you say that you like smells,
that makes it sound like you like the smell of smegma.
I don't know what it smells like. Maybe I do.
I don't know what it smells like either.
Have you seen what smegma looks like?
Yeah, you can...
Look it up?
There's subreddit dedicated to it.
Because people are into it.
There's subreddit dedicated to smegma?
Yeah.
Like smegma lovers.
r slash smegma lovers.
Don't look it up. That's a real subreddit.
No fucking way.
There's an r slash smegma lovers?
Don't look it. It's disgusting.
I'm looking up r slash smegma lovers.
No, don't.
It's actually fucking disgusting.
Don't.
I want to see it.
I want to see it really badly.
I've never...
I clicked on one out of curiosity before
and I nearly threw up.
You can't throw up.
It's disgusting.
I looked at it again myself.
Wait, I don't even see anything.
What am I looking at?
It's just...
I don't see it.
Wait.
No, I think we must look like the same image.
I think we saw the same one.
I think we saw...
I kind of want to see more.
Okay, I'll stop.
Oh god.
I told you.
I wasn't exaggerating.
I wasn't...
I told you, don't lie.
And you know what?
It's not as bad as I expected it to be,
but it's still really gross.
You nearly threw up.
I don't even know it's not as bad as you expected.
Some of them are even worse.
Those are like...
Send me your worst one.
We can look at the top post together.
The top post of all time?
Yeah, from that subject.
I'll do it. I'll stream it to you.
I'll open it and stream it to you.
You'll open it and stream it together.
This is what the stream is.
I'm going to share my stream.
Ignore my million tabs.
Don't share this. I'm so scared.
I'm not sharing it, don't worry.
Wait, I just realized I'm still streaming to you anyway.
Is that the fuck?
Oh god.
The fucking tab is titled
Ripe smelly cheese forest.
For skin.
Ripe smelly cheesy for skin.
Okay.
Top all time.
Okay, all time.
Smells amazing.
16 hours ago.
This is fun today.
Smells amazing.
Do you want to look at this one 16 hours ago?
Sure.
Okay.
It's not that bad.
Go all time.
I need to see the thickest,
most disgusting,
chunkiest one, you know?
Why bother cleaning it
when it just keeps coming back?
Am I right?
This has 901 of votes.
I'm actually scared.
Open it.
What?
I don't see it.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Wait.
That's what I was expecting.
I was expecting that for like every
every single post.
I was expecting that for every
That's like really intense.
Yeah.
I was expecting that for every single post.
That's like really intense.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
Oh god.
No idea.
My eyes are so watery.
Holy shit.
Thank you for introducing me
to Slash's Make My Lovers.
You're welcome.
I would have never had that
in my life if it weren't for you.
I would have gone
my entire life without
seeing that.
I don't even,
I get curious and I go down like
rabbit holes sometimes, but that one was too far.
Like I literally, like I can't.
I thought I had like a strong stomach,
but I literally just the visual
is enough to get me going.
Yeah.
Like I, the video,
the video is even worse than just the photo.
It is, because you see it like
popping out.
Don't describe it.
Don't even like, I can't,
even like the description.
Ugh.
You don't want to think about it
popping out of the top.
Good.
I don't want to, no.
What do you mean there's worse videos
if you are interested?
I'm absolutely not interested.
I couldn't even finish that one.
I have a little bit of
morbid curiosity,
so I kind of want to see, but also
please don't, please don't send me.
Please don't send me videos
of your, of your smegma
dick.
I'm good.
You're going to end up with videos of them.
No.
Yes, the smegma pops out.
That is what she's describing.
She's disgusting.
If it's a niche and some smegas,
some smegma's fine, right? No!
No.
Not just some.
I think like a little bit, but this is not a little bit.
No.
Not even some is fine.
Please don't have any smegma.
Thank you.
Is it too much to ask?
True.
I don't even, that video had
901 uploads.
Not only did not, like
at least 901 people,
well more than 901 people
have seen it, but 901
people saw that and liked it.
I liked it.
I feel like it was all guys too.
I feel like it's all just guys liking each other's smegma.
It definitely has to be.
Yeah.
But it's still like, even like 901 people,
901 people saw them like, yeah.
And went, yeah, that's hot.
That's hot.
And I couldn't even like finish the video,
like that's one of the worst things.
I think I would rather watch somebody like eat a pile of shit.
Like,
there are a few things I can think of
that are worse than that.
I don't know what it, it's just fucking disgusting.
There was a wife involved
in like the fourth
of all time post.
Yeah, oh yeah, he mentions, like, yeah,
I saw he like mentions his wife, like
helps keep it clean.
I assume it's like a video of his wife
literally like taking the smegma.
Ew!
I didn't, I didn't look at it.
Did you look at it?
No, I don't want to see it.
I feel like that's even more gross to watch someone eat it.
Like,
that's worse.
That's worse than what we've already seen,
to watch someone eat it.
That's weird.
You
assume it's guys looking at that subreddit
when it's literally DEMPA telling us about it?
DEMPA, how do you know about that?
I don't even remember.
I just, I browse reddit
and I find things on reddit.
I've looked a lot at, like, um,
there's like,
a museum of reddit filth.
I'm just in general like close to that archive,
like cursed reddit content.
So I think I found it when I was searching for like
cursed reddit content
that was like linked in like,
cursed subreddit.
So I was like, what is this?
What's the worst thing you've seen on reddit?
Uh,
have you seen the poop in the condoms?
What?
The poop condoms.
The,
the what?
Reddit, reddit,
poop condoms.
Let me try to find it.
That condom.
Scat?
Yeah, it was in,
wait, I think it's in like the museum of reddit filth.
I can't find it.
I don't know, maybe someone in chat, but there's
like, it's like an old post of a guy
who like, stores his own poop
in condoms. Oh wait, yeah.
He like, stored his own poop in condoms
and to like, keep?
Yeah.
I've heard of the guy who stored his own poop in jars
and then his wife found out about it.
No.
But in condoms?
Oh, you guys do know.
Yeah, they know.
What's it called? Is it a subreddit or is it just one guy?
It's just one guy.
But I don't know where,
I don't know how to find it.
And I found like, I tried to find it
and I found a guy
eating poop condoms.
I found?
Oh, what the fuck.
I found a post from four years ago
that says, will I get sick if I continue
to inhale a decoration I made from my restroom?
A scat condom?
The whole place smells like poop but it looks cool
and then it's just a video of him like,
flicking it around
and like, holding it and like, squishing it.
Ooh, ooh, oh wow.
Oh, he's like milking it like,
milking it like a cow udder.
And like, punching it.
I feel like that's not it.
But it's the less gross version
but it's still pretty nasty.
Basically, the poop condom
is like a whole genre.
It's like a whole,
it's a whole thing because like I said,
I was trying to find it.
Maybe? So I was trying to find it
and like I said, I couldn't find the exact one
because there's so much that shows up
when you try to find poop condoms.
So much shows up.
Sorry, can you repeat that?
So much shows up when you search
for like poop condoms.
Oh, so you can't find the original?
Yeah, there's so many.
There's too much poop condom content.
I read it post too much poop condom.
It's called the Alaskan Pipeline.
Oh, yeah, the Alaskan Pipeline!
What?
I think that is what I've heard it called,
the Alaskan Pipeline.
The Alaskan Pipeline.
So should I search up Alaskan Pipeline?
I guess. Wait, let me look at the Alaskan Pipeline.
No, it's called the Alaskan...
Wait, no!
No, no, wait, no, wait.
No.
Oh, wait, no, yes!
The act of pooping into a condom,
freezing the rubber overnight
and then inserting it into one's anus,
that is called the Alaskan Pipeline.
What the fuck?
Yeah, so you'll find like a lot of people.
Yeah, this is like a thing.
Wait, you'll find people?
Is there like videos of people doing that?
Yes, they post them on the internet.
Should I look it up?
No, you shouldn't.
I shouldn't.
Well, if you're into that I guess,
if you're like interested.
I don't think it'll do you good.
Like I don't think it'll help.
I just see the transit Alaskan Pipeline.
I guess it's not, it must not be popular,
but I found a post saying help,
it's a Facebook post and it says,
help, my boyfriend was out of town
and I was super horny.
I didn't have any sex toys so long story short,
I decided to try something new
and I shot in a condom and froze it.
Apparently it's called an Alaskan Pipeline.
Anyway, midway through the big,
oh, the condom broke, but I didn't stop.
I just want to know if I can get an infection from it.
I mean, it did come from my own body,
so I think I'm fine.
There's no way that's not as real.
That was like someone's bait post.
What year is this from?
Um, it's a screenshot of a Facebook post from three years ago.
And the Facebook post itself doesn't have a timestamp.
I mean everything on Facebook is like definitely fake,
but like also,
yeah, I guess just the poop thing is like common.
It's a common thing.
It's really fucked up.
There's a lot of people
on Reddit asking,
like has anyone done this?
Because they're like,
no, because they're like,
I want to do this. Do you guys have experience?
Why though?
Yeah, that's true.
I don't want to use your own shit.
It's got to be some sort of like,
like you could literally use like a brush handle,
a bottle, like fucking your fingers.
You could.
Like why?
It's like that guy who got Salmonella
from having eggs with a chicken breast?
With a chicken breast?
A chicken breast?
I heard about the coconut guy.
Like the Reddit coconut guy or like the Combox guy?
Have you heard about the Reddit shoebox guy?
I have heard about the Reddit shoebox guy.
I think I even saw the picture of his shoebox too.
Yeah, the Combox with the pictures.
That one's kind of classic.
That one wasn't really that gross.
I think because it was like,
maybe this gross.
I can't even find like a picture because this was like,
this was 12 years ago.
It's an old thing for sure.
It's, oh no, I didn't realize.
Oops, I'm not old.
I don't know. 12 years ago.
I was still...
You were still what?
I was still on my planet, my home planet.
Yeah, I was still young.
It's still in my mother's womb 12 years ago.
No, you can't say that on me.
Wait, I'm switching again.
I mean, I...
Wait, I'm an adult.
I am an adult.
You're my favorite adult.
Thank you.
He cut the chicken breast and half and fricked it.
Why would you do that?
He was cooking naked.
Okay, that sounds like an excuse.
That sounds like the excuse he would give Reddit to be like,
did I fuck up chat?
So I accidentally spilled soda on my pants while I was cooking,
so I had to take my pants off.
And then, you know, the chicken breast was just looking really,
really irresistible.
Yeah, I don't think...
I don't think you just accidentally fucked the chicken breast.
It's a little bit hard to do that.
And then suddenly next thing I know,
I just slipped into it and I couldn't stop thrusting.
I was washing potatoes in the bath and one slipped in my butt.
No.
I think I've actually seen, like, people, like, Reddit posts,
again, where people are like...
I think, like, people going to the ER for things in their butt
is pretty common because stuff gets, like, stuck.
But I don't know about accidentally getting your penis stuck inside of the chicken.
No, it's...
The post isn't about getting your penis stuck inside of a chicken.
It was about a guy who fucked the chicken and got a salmonella.
Wait, you can get salmonella through your penis?
Can you? I guess, apparently.
Well, how else did he get it if he didn't get it from his penis?
Did he, like, eat the raw chicken after fucking it?
Well, it's back...
You get salmonella from fucking its chicken breast.
It's bacteria, right? Salmonella is a...
Is it a bacterial infection or is it a...
What kind of infection is it? Is it a viral infection?
I don't know.
How do you... Can you Google...
Hey Google, can you get salmonella from putting your penis inside of the raw chicken?
Hey Siri, can you get salmonella from putting your penis inside of a raw chicken?
Cool. Can she actually answer this?
The member has a hole, too. It does have a hole, but it just...
I don't know, you don't expect it to...
Oh my god, you made me so freaking adorable with the striped socks, too.
Holy shit!
Your socks are powerful.
I wish I could blend. My coloring looks so sloppin'.
I know. I know, it's really hard to blend.
I usually use watercolor brushes, except for more textures, so I feel like it...
I just... I don't know. I think it looks okay.
It looks so good! Are you kidding me?
It's just not ideal coloring. I'm trying, though.
You made me adorable. Don't worry about it.
I know this program is hard to use. You did amazing with what you had.
You did great.
Yeah, the thigh high.
Make me a ginger? Oh, right. It's okay. It's okay for now. It's fine.
Read it. Read it. Read it.
What if you were a Reddit alien?
Actually, you're... No, no, I'm so sorry, but the things on the end of your twin tails,
they kind of look like a Reddit alien if you look at it.
They do look like the Reddit character, you mean?
Yes, no. I think our name is...
No. It literally looks like the Reddit alien, but instead of two balls, it's three balls.
Okay, let me look up what you're talking about.
Reddit alien next to your twin tail.
You literally have an upside down Reddit alien with three balls on your twin tails.
I do.
How do I flip it? How the fuck do I flip things in this program?
How do I fucking rotate it? Just rotate the whole...
Wait, no. They can't see it if I rotate it.
I'll rotate myself.
How do I make it upside down?
Oh, there it is. Wait. No, I can't rotate it, so...
I can't... Oh, there. There it is.
No, it's literally... Yeah, it actually does have three balls because it has the antenna, too.
It's literally...
It's literally identical.
You just wrote to the alien.
Yeah, it's literally identical.
It's literally the man.
Wait, the Seabat Reddit story.
Isn't that just the story of the guy that freaks to Seabat?
Yeah, he just had sex to the song.
Oh, that's so tame.
I like that song.
That's a bad song.
What? What do you mean I like it?
I, ironically, like that song.
It's a bad song.
At least it's a bad song. How is it a bad song?
Like, it's like...
It's got such a shitty tempo.
What? No, that's what makes it awesome.
It's like different. It's so good to work through.
Like, I shit my ass to it. It's fucking awesome.
Proof or it didn't happen.
I'm listening to it right now.
I'll do a cover of it. I'll sing it and be obnoxious right now.
I'll sing on stream.
It doesn't have lyrics. What are you gonna sing?
No, sing it. I'll sing the song.
Wait, sing it. Sing it. I want you to sing it to me.
I'm gonna sing you the song and I want you to sing it.
See that karaoke. See that karaoke.
It doesn't have lyrics, though.
It does.
It does?
What? I thought it was just...
The lyrics are...
No, the lyrics go...
I can type them out for you. I can write the lyrics for you if you need them.
That's just instrumental.
No, it's not. It's the lyrics.
That's not horrible either, the magnetic beads.
Did you hear about the guy that got 12 tiny horse miniatures stuck inside of his beanus?
How does that fit? How many were the horses? How small?
Or maybe it was his butt. It might be his butt.
Oh, that would make more sounds. How many are these horses? Those have to be mini horses.
Miniature horse stick inside of his beanus.
Even miniature miniature horses. You can't, definitely.
Put some big things in there, but...
Yeah, the butt makes more sounds than the urethra.
I can't find the video.
I don't want to see the video. I don't want to see the video and find the horse.
I can't find the actual news or story of it. I don't think he showed a video of it.
Maybe it's made up.
It could be.
I guess if it were his butt, that makes a lot more sounds.
Yeah, it does.
That's a lot of horse miniatures to put inside of your urethra.
That is a lot of horse miniatures, you're right.
Have you seen those really cool little babies?
No.
Oh shit, did Strani read us?
Oh, Strani's just here. What did I just come into? Oh, not much.
Hi, Strani.
Hello. Hi, Strani. That's my first collab with Amy and me.
You missed the best part.
Yeah, we're just drawing. We're not doing anything else. We're just drawing.
No.
Nothing else is going on here.
What's smegma?
Smegma? I don't know. I've never heard of that. I've never seen that. I don't know what that is.
Do you know Denpa?
Never heard of it before.
No, maybe we should look it up.
I really want to get some of those mini babies for crafts. I was going to get some before.
I saw them at a store when I was traveling, but then they were cash only and I didn't have any cash because it was in different currencies.
I never got the weird little baby, weird baby beads. Weird baby beads.
But I also lived in a place and they put the babies everywhere. The weird babies.
I'm not sure.
No, I searched weird babies and I got weird baby.
I have a choker with a baby, like a little baby figure on it.
Yeah, I had a lot of those. I'm getting some really fucked up babies on the internet.
These are kind of cool. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Do you see that?
What the fuck is that?
They're being mean.
They look like rat babies, like little jelly beans, like hamster babies.
Those aren't the babies that were in my house.
Those weren't the babies that were in my house, but they're different babies. They were like weird little babies.
I'm trying to find the babies.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean to put that one there.
It's okay.
Do you like them?
I do. I do. It's very cute. I would definitely wear those around my neck.
Weird babies.
Baby beads?
Baby beads.
No, these are like beads for babies. I want baby beads.
I'm getting baby toys.
Beads resembling babies.
Oh, hell yeah.
Mini plastic babies.
Crafting baby dolls for baby shower, shower, ice cube game.
Party decorations, baby birthday favors, baby bathing brown.
They were like these.
Yeah, I have that, yeah.
Yeah, these babies. These babies are awesome. Oh my god, there's colored ones.
It's like, ew.
What do you mean colored ones? Like different, like rainbows?
Yeah, like, this is so fucking scary.
Holy shit. Why did they arrange them like this?
Why did they arrange them like this?
They look like creepy little aliens.
Baby satan circle.
Oh my god.
Mini plastic babies will be fun to put on top of anything.
It shows them like taking over. Look at these.
They kind of look like the things around your neck.
Mini plastic babies will be fun to put on top of anything.
What the fuck?
This is the kind of shit that people would put inside them for sure.
Yeah, like I could see that being inside of something.
The mini horse is like around this.
Yeah, but any bigger and I don't think it would fit.
I mean, you know, people, people, people find a way.
Imagine wood soup with these. What is wood soup?
It's like an ASMR trigger thing.
Oh.
With like the bowls with the wooden beads.
I know what you're talking about. Yeah.
Yeah, I don't like those. I hate the sounds that it makes.
Really? I kind of like them.
Yeah, I really don't like the sound of like stuff in water.
Like bobbing around like anything like soupy.
I don't really fuck with it.
No?
No, I'm not a big fan.
I'm a big fan. I like here.
Ah!
What did you do?
I'm sorry.
You're the worst little sister I've ever had.
I hope I'm the only sister you've ever had.
You are.
Okay, so I'm also the best too, right?
Yeah, but you're also the worst.
Well, that's okay. I can be both.
As long as I'm the best, it's okay.
You're the best at being the worst.
At least I'm the best at something.
You're the best at cleaning Smegma.
I don't want to be the best at that.
I don't want to be the best at cleaning Smegma.
No.
Why not? What's wrong with Smegma?
You can be the best at cleaning Smegma, okay?
No.
You're the best. You're so good at it.
I've never done that before.
So I'm not good at it. I've never done it before.
What do you mean you did it to me last night?
You get Smegma?
Yeah.
You grow your own Smegma?
Yeah, I grow it.
I farm it.
You farm your own Smegma?
Yeah.
Do you sell it? What do you do with it?
I don't sell it.
You can turn it into cheese.
It's a delicacy.
Have you tried it yourself?
Yeah, I love it.
You love it?
Mm-hmm.
Oh my god.
What the f**k?
Then I'm sponsored by the Canadian Smegma Farmers.
No!
No farming sponsors ever.
Emmy can do farm sponsors.
She loves farming.
I don't like farmers.
What do you have against farmers now?
You hate farmers too?
First Smegma now farms?
What do you like?
Do you hate farmers?
I don't really have any strong opinions about them.
I don't think I really think about farmers that much.
I don't think about farmers either.
But I don't want to farm Smegma.
Why not?
It's vegan.
It's like the vegan alternative to cheese.
Yeah, it's vegan cheese.
I'm not vegan, so I don't really need to farm it.
Farmer pin pals, it's over.
No!
The pin balls, not the pin balls.
The farmer pin balls, I never recover.
I'm sorry.
Any farmer pin balls out there,
you'll never have a chance to farm Smegma with me.
It's so fucking over.
They were banking on the collabs.
They were trying to get the farmer collabs.
The farmer collabs with Emmy's famous Emmy beats.
Sorry, it's never happening.
Farmer hates.
I have all VTubers hate farmers in the farming industry.
I don't think VTubers and farmers really have a really similar fan base.
I don't think they have many, you know, overlapping fans.
There's farmers that have Facebooks.
I was going to say, do you think they have fan bases?
They're like, oh yeah, farmer John back in it again.
I love it when you post on Facebook.
The highlight of the day is this Facebook farmer's post.
There has to be, because there's dating sites for farmers.
I don't remember what it was called.
It was called onlyfarmers.com or farmersonly.com or something like that.
And it's like a whole dating site for farmers.
Do you know that one?
Onlyfarmers.
I don't know it.
I've seen, like, I know there's a lot of, like, niche dating sites, I guess,
because everyone is like...
Yeah, it's called farmersonly.com.
Single in the country.
And then you put your email address, zip code,
and then you save your woman or man and your age.
And then you can search for other farmers.
Should I search for farmers in my area?
Yeah, see if there's any, like, sexy farmers.
Okay.
I feel like, I feel like I'm just going to find, like, a bunch of really old people.
Don't you like those?
Well, I'm imagining, like, 70, 80.
Yeah, like, almost 70, but maybe like, like, like 50, like, you know,
not many young people own farms, you know?
You should try to, like, date them and explain to B2B to, like, a farmer.
Wait, this is American, right?
This has to be an American site.
I need an American zip code.
American...
McDonald's Florida zip code.
Here.
I want to use the McDonald's in Boca Raton, Florida.
Boca Raton?
That's not a real place.
Boca Raton.
Wait, I don't understand how...
How do you spell Boca Raton?
I don't understand how zip codes work for Americans.
I just put a number.
I am a woman looking for a man.
Enter my age.
30.
Search now.
I'm Amy.
I'm 30, and I'm looking for a farmer that can...
My age.
Oh, my God.
There's actually 7,000...
Oh, wait, that's members.
I thought there were 7,000 farmers in Boca Raton, McDonald's, Florida.
See, that's a lot of...
This is a big...
I guess it's a big farmer's thing.
Maybe.
You know what?
Some of them aren't actually that old.
I guess...
Oh, you know what?
I think it's because I put my age as 30.
It's showing me other farmers that are around 30 years old, you know?
Can you change the ages?
I want to see really old farmers.
You want to see old farmers?
Imagine a sexy old lady farmer.
She's a lesbian.
Lesbian farmer lady who butchers.
So you want me to look for the girl farmers?
Yeah, I want a sexy, sexy, 50-year-old farmer.
And she's a regular smoker.
I can choose a lot.
Oh, wait, no, that's my own...
That's never mind.
Never mind.
I thought I could choose...
No, I wanted to be a smoker.
Yeah, I wanted to be a smoker.
I wanted to smoke cigarettes and put them around me.
Lesbian farmer.
Okay, wait, edit my profile.
I'm a female looking for female employment.
Apparently they automatically chose that I raise alpacas.
How do I change my age so I can get farmers around my age?
Save.
I don't know.
They don't let me change unless I put my first name and last name.
Farmer girl is my first name and last name.
I wonder how many people I named farmer girl.
Okay, my ideal match is between the ages of 55 and 99.
And I want someone that's a regular smoker and body type.
Big and beautiful.
And I'm looking for long term.
They're the options.
Big and beautiful.
Oh, the options for the body type.
There's slim, average, athletic, a few extra pounds.
Pleasantly plump, big and beautiful.
And then tell you later.
I don't know what tell you later.
Tell you later.
What does tell you later mean?
I don't know, but I like it.
Tell you later.
Let's see who my new matches are now.
How do I go?
How do I?
I don't know.
I got canceled on Reddit before because I said I had a 65 year old girlfriend.
And you got canceled on Reddit for that?
Yeah, I posted in like crawler sightings and I said my girlfriend's 65.
This on her ring camera last night.
Does anyone know what this is?
And all their replies are about my 65 year old girlfriend that doesn't exist.
And I mean, this is my image.
What the fuck is that?
What do you think it is?
What does it look like?
I don't know.
My 65 year old girlfriend caught it on her doorbell.
I don't see anything in that photo.
What do you see?
Nothing.
What do you mean you see?
It's real.
Is that an alien?
Yeah, it is.
Oh.
It's me, but all the comments, I got like 486 comments from people trying to guess what
it was.
It's literally like my brood model, but they're like, it's a bug selfie right up on the camera.
And they're like arguing.
Wait, what is it actually though?
It's my brood.
It's me.
What?
Did you edit it?
I have big eyes.
What the fuck is going on?
Whoa.
You know what?
Some of these farmer, I found a 68 year old farmer lady that actually is really muscular.
Is that what you're into?
Wait, I want to see if she's sexy.
She's cute.
Wait, so hard to me.
She's not bad at all.
Her name is cowgirl.
What?
Her name is cowgirl and then followed by a bunch of numbers.
I sent her, I sent you her profile.
She's pretty muscular.
Cowgirl.
No, I need to make an account.
What is this website?
Search now.
Why does this website look like this?
It's really bad.
Most of the farmer ladies that are 70 year olds, 70 year old don't really want to show
their pictures.
I'm a man looking for a woman and I'm 65.
Search now.
Take a photo.
No, I don't want a photo.
Well, there's 7,359 people on the menu now.
That's crazy.
Oh, there's some cameras.
Oh, whoa.
I'm learning some cute formulas.
Learn for free, favorite.
Looking for a wife, please help me.
She likes is 4'3 to 7'11.
She's really keeping her options open.
Yeah, she's speaking of women ages 24 to 68.
Oh my.
She's 4 foot 3 to 7 foot 11.
Yeah, I mean, she's keeping her options open, you know?
Don't want to miss anyone that might be your soulmate just because they're 4 foot 2 or 4 foot 3.
Or 7 foot 11.
Is that even possible?
To be 7 foot 11? I don't know. Is it? Probably.
There's probably some people out there that are 7-eleven.
There's no way. 7-eleven?
7-eleven.
That's way too big.
Nobody is 7-eleven.
Maybe they are.
No way.
What? Are you saying all the 7-eleven people aren't allowed to have dating profiles now?
No, I'm saying that. I don't think anyone that tall exists.
I'm sure they do.
Yeah, any 7-eleven pin pals out there?
Make yourself known.
Now. Speak now or forever.
Hold your something. I don't know how it goes.
Speak now or forever. Hold your piece.
I don't know.
I'm struggling so much with this line.
Real and surreal and valid.
So true to start. Sorry, I don't know what came over me.
It's okay. The tallest person living is 8 feet tall.
So 8 feet 2.8 inches.
It would have to...
No, not even that guy would qualify because he's too tall.
Yeah, but I'm saying if the tallest person in the world is 8 feet tall, then 7-eleven is still completely, you know, achievable.
How tall are you?
Oh, unfortunately I'm...
Fuck, I never remembered my height, to be honest.
It's like 4...
It starts at 140 centimeters there. I remember the...
Oh, small.
Yeah.
I love Indian.
And you're so quiet as soon.
Did you say that or is that someone in chat that said that?
Me.
Oh, thank you.
Why, were you hoping it was a chatter? You're disappointed that I said it.
No, I just wasn't sure if you were reading out chatter or if you were saying that yourself.
No.
They're just discussing heights now, I think.
I'm 4'5'9".
4'5'9".
4.59 feet, so basically I'm 5'9", basically.
5'9", that's kind of tall, 5'9".
Yeah, it's pretty tall.
It's not bad, right?
5 feet tall and 9 inches.
Not bad at all.
Why are you so tall?
I just had a growth spurt, you know.
Oh.
You're so cool.
She's overcompensating, I'm not overcompensating for nothing.
I'm very cool and tall.
Oh shit, I keep accidentally downloading my drawing.
Why are you, is it like a hot key?
Yeah, I keep Ctrl-S'ing, because that's how I save my art in normal art programs.
But in this thing, yeah, in this thing, Ctrl-S is to download the drawing you're working on.
So I keep downloading it.
What?
Evil?
What if you were sick and twisted?
What does that mean? What do you mean?
Just wait, what if you were sick and twisted?
Are you referencing me? What do you mean, sick and twisted?
No, you're not saying it right.
What? How am I supposed to say it?
Sick and twisted.
I've never heard that before. Is this what kind of meme?
What is sick and twisted?
I don't know, I just made it up.
Okay.
You're making up your own memes?
Yeah, I'm inventing them just for you. Do you like it?
Thank you, yeah. I love sick and twisted.
No, you said it wrong again.
How am I supposed to say it?
Sick and twisted.
Yeah, you need to say it like, twisted.
You need to be twisted. You need to sound twisted.
Don't even say it's twisted.
What?
Hey guys, it's me and me of the first generation, the Allure generation in Daud.
And I'm sick and twisted.
You want me to say that?
Yes.
Hey guys, it's me and me from the first generation of the Allure and Daud.
And I'm sick and twisted.
Are you happy?
Do you want to say something actually like sick and twisted?
Sure.
I checked my emails really quickly.
Okay, I have my farmers only registration and then I got another email, but it's just the arrangement is funny.
Why did someone try to DM you on farmersonly.com?
No, it's the juxtaposition.
Wait, I sent it in the DM.
The order. It's literally like four minutes after.
Oh my god, you got invited to be a Twitch partner?
Yeah, but it's directly next to the farmers only.
It's like to activate your farmers only.com account.
Congratulations.
I'm sick and twisted.
That's so exciting.
I went to go check for my farmers only information.
I wanted to activate my farmers only account.
I used the same email.
I got that.
That's so exciting.
You don't have to add anything if you're done.
I want to draw some pimples.
I just keep drawing because you're still drawing so I keep going.
Yeah, I was trying to polish it a bit.
I don't know.
I don't know, that's really polished.
I'm like, my brain doesn't work right.
That's okay.
I don't know how to draw a pimple.
We have pimples and we have dent pals.
Wait, is that the name of your fan base, dent pals?
Yeah, dent pals. We both have pals.
Oh my god, I have no clue. That's so cute.
Yeah, pals, pals, pals. The pals can be pals together.
Dent pals and kin pals.
What do the dent pals look like?
I'll draw one. I was going to get an image, a reference image,
but it's quicker to draw one.
It literally looks exactly like this, but green.
That's adorable. I love dent pals.
This is literally dent pals.
It looks like a cute little booger. I love it.
Yeah, this is a pretty cute little booger.
I agree. They're pretty kawaii boogers.
Make the dent pals and the kin pals make out with each other?
No, dent pals only have sex with other dent pals.
Well, they don't have sex. They asexually produce.
Well, they can just kiss. They don't have to have sex.
They can just kiss.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, that's no problem here.
I don't want them to be ludified.
It's not ludiculesome.
I don't want any luded dent pals.
It should be a crime.
There will not be a single luded dent pal.
Thank god. It's a luded dent pal.
Wow, I found a cigarette, bro. I found a cigarette.
What if you were sick and twisted and had a cigarette?
I forgot that I had this.
Wait, can I put this? Wait.
Let me get this shit on me.
Let me get this shit on.
What if we both had cigarette?
Cigarettes and arts.
I'm like, wait, where'd it go?
There it is. Wait, this is...
Oh god, I don't even know what this works. Do you see my arm?
I do see the cigarette hand, yeah.
Okay, just like...
Crop me.
Just a cigarette.
I have my pen in one hand and a cigarette in the other.
It is so sick and twisted.
I love just smoking a cigarette.
Hanging out with my little sis.
And then putting the cigarette butts on her.
What?
You don't need to cover your breasts and bandages
when you can just use bruises.
To cover my boobs?
Not built on censorship.
But bruises to cover my boobs? What?
Yeah.
I don't understand.
Because then it wouldn't be skin colored.
But I think the algorithm will still understand that it's boobs.
And then I'll get banned for showing tits on youtube.com.
No, you're literally topless right now.
Can you show me how you can color in your using the bucket tool?
What is this? It's nothing so disgusting!
What?
He's lying to me!
What's wrong with him? He's kissing the tin pal.
He's kissing the tin pal.
It has a gross border but you just need to make sure that the line is closed.
That's the only thing, that the line is closed.
And I just did it on the same layer because it makes life easier.
I'm really bad at making sure the line is closed.
I'll just quickly shittily color it in there.
What's the pin pal reference again?
Give me the pin pal.
I don't even have any.
Let me see if I can send you one.
It's gonna start.
There, I sent you.
I still don't know why my name is sound wizard.
It just got changed.
Wait, I think I can change it.
I didn't realize I could change it.
Wait.
Oh, now I'm dump a bush.
That's so fucking weird.
Oh, there he is. He's so cute. I really like him.
He reminds me kind of of the pumpkins in Steven Universe.
Do you like Steven Universe?
I've never watched Steven Universe.
It's like really later in the series but they have a character that's just a pumpkin.
But it's like a pet pumpkin. It's sentient.
It's a sentient cat pumpkin.
Let me look it up.
Steven Universe is the talking one.
There's a talking pumpkin.
Steven Universe's pumpkin is the first thing that shows up as a pumpkin guy.
Oh, I see him. I see him.
Oh, he's so cute.
And there's a watermelon one too.
One of Steven's powers is to make sentient plants and stuff.
Can you spit?
Ew.
Yeah, he got spit on a pumpkin and he accidentally made it come to life.
That's adorable. I see what you mean.
Yeah, it's kind of the same thing.
You should watch Steven Universe. Do you want to watch it with me?
Sure, we can. I've never watched it before. I've never seen it.
It never seemed interesting to me.
I think you might at least like the art.
The background art is really nice.
Pin pals.
Ta-da!
Ta-da! Why are they kissing?
They're kissing?
What is their shouldn't they? Den pin pals?
Den... Den pin... Oh, you're right.
Den pin pals.
Pin den pals.
Pen...
Pin pals.
Pen... Pen pals.
Big pen pals. They become pen pals.
Pen pals?
Pen... Pen plus den.
Pen pals.
Yeah, they can be pen pals now, yeah.
Pen pals, yeah.
Coink.
What did their baby look like?
I don't know.
This one would be like pumpkin-headed.
I didn't think it was that weird.
Pumpkin-headed.
Crossbreeding the pals.
This...
I'm trying to draw it. It looks absolutely disgusting.
No, it's not that bad. It looks like a cute little ghost.
Oh, go, go, go.
I like their pumpkin mouth. Pumpkin mouths are really cute.
Like a pumpkin.
Yeah.
And then he needs the thing.
And then his little knees.
And then he just has like little melons.
Wait, that's actually really cute.
It is so cute.
What is it called, the pen pals?
I guess so.
Wait, that is actually cute.
Oh, I love him.
I'll make him orange with like...
What?
And yeah, he closed the holes really quickly here.
Did he close them?
He did not.
You can tell they like the fucking leg that...
Oh, there it is.
It's so hard to see the little holes of me drawing.
In the air, each of the bosoms barely touch it.
You're gonna touch yours?
I don't have a bosom to fucking touch with Denpa's bosoms.
Yeah, and I think you two might not like it.
You two might not like it.
The way you show a little bit of my boobs,
you two might not like that.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
I'll make a censored version.
You can put like an emoji over it.
No, I don't want to put an emoji.
I could put...
We can put fishnet over top of that,
and that's probably enough to censor it.
Like a fishnet shirt.
Yeah.
Make it fashionably censored.
Yeah, okay.
I forgot that YouTubers like that.
Do you rip your fishnets off them?
I don't rip my fishnets.
I rip my regular...
I at least find really cheap
types from Goodwill and I rip those.
Oh, I see.
I rip fishnets by accident a lot.
It's so easy to end up like putting
thing in the wrong hole.
Like I put my leg in the wrong hole.
I'm really stupid. I think I'm too dumb for like,
nettings.
There, that's good.
I don't know if I love it.
I don't love how it like,
put the fishnet on.
You don't like it?
It's censored.
I probably didn't draw it very well,
but I can't undo anymore,
so I guess it's there forever.
Here we go.
I'm spying.
Censorship.
Fuck YouTube censorship.
Your line art looks so good.
How are you so good at lines?
I know you're a really good artist,
but damn, your line art is so good,
and also you're doing it in this fucking program.
Thank you.
I'm gonna download the Photoshop file for this
so that I can continue.
Wait, it won't let me download the Photoshop file?
Why can't, how do I do that?
Oh, X4 as PSD.
X4 does, yeah.
You need to fucking sign up for premium
to have the layers?
Wait, no, wait, seriously, hold on.
Let me see if I can open it with the layers.
Layer images.
You need to go upgrade the blades to get access.
There is the free trial.
Free seven day trial.
Well, it's so generous.
Hold on a sec.
Photoshop.
No, I have the layers when I download it
as a Photoshop file, I got the layers.
Okay, I guess for some reason
it shows like the red icon
with the layer images
that is usually indicative
of it being a premium feature.
I'm glad it's not.
Yeah, that would be fucking sucky.
Okay, I'm getting really fucking hot
in my room right now.
So I'm gonna
stop there for today.
I don't know.
Thank you for joining with me.
It looks really lovely so far.
Is this thumbnail worthy?
It is thumbnail worthy.
Absolutely, it's thumbnail worthy.
I don't know.
I could do more, but at the same time,
I'm like, not some more.
I don't know what else to do right now.
It's unworthy.
It's adorable, it's thumbnail worthy.
Don't worry about it.
I really like the pen pal.
I think he's very cute.
The pumpkin pal.
I forgot that I put this on
because I'm not looking at it there.
I'm done smoking.
I'll bring you my tentacles.
You can put them on yourself.
You can have tentacles.
Thank you.
It's a treat.
Just a little treat.
Thank you for joining with me.
Really looking forward to our ASMR together.
It'll be so good to you.
To me?
Or to the viewers?
I love it. I'd be nice to them.
I'm going to write you
as being nice to the viewers in the script.
You would never.
You would never?
Well, you're going to have to be nice to them this time.
Oh my god, you're tentacles
are tentacling everywhere.
I'm touching your rotten aliens.
I'm going to raid Shibi.
So,
it'll be nice to Shibi, everyone.
Yeah, it'll be very nice to her.
She's doing an ASMR where she's
doing everyone's makeup.
They are nice to me.
Yeah, I love makeup ASMR.
It's the best kind of ASMR.
You guys should listen.
Makeup ASMR is the best.
It is. It's relaxing.
Mommy Shibi does your makeup.
Wait,
I remember it was like sister Shibi.
I don't know.
I think it's Onesan.
Onesan Shibi.
Yeah.
Okay, well, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Thank you for coming.
I'm going to go put it on the
ending screen now. Bye.
Bye.
Let's go.